l'arboretum des grandes bruyères niché
au coeur de la forêt d'orléans forme
avec son entrée par un jardin à la
française
l'un des plus beaux contrastes paysages
et des jardins remarquables de large
derrière ce jardin sur 10 hectares se
trouvent les collections de l'arboretum
roses anciennes magnolia arbres et
arbustes d'europe d'amérique du nord et
d'extrême orient
au total huit jardins et 2 arboretum qui
composent le parc l'atmosphère du lieu
pourrait donner à croire que ce jardin
est ici depuis des siècles
pourtant voilà quarante ans les 15
hectares n'était que broussailles et
friches
seul un vieux chêne de 200 ans étaient
présents
histoire de l'arboretum est intimement
liée à celle de ses créateurs brigitte
et berna qui dans les années 70 se sont
lancés avec passion dans l'amour de la
nature et du paysage protéger la nature
et le patrimoine on utilise le mot
patrimoine maintenant le mot patrimoine
végétal et botanique
ça va devenir à l'avenir de plus en plus
importants ailleurs aucun doute c'est ça
que je dois faire avec mes 15 hectares
allait faire une exploitation forestière
sauf qu'un acteur blague
tandis qu'un arbre et un de 15 ha ça
peut être très beau la preuve le voilà
il ya quarante tonnes soit je parte cet
état c'était une friche agricole
abandonné en a mis cinq ans à découvrir
le fabuleux j'aime la qui était
manifestement mulet d'un après les
quelques témoignages de gens de mon âge
à cette époque là qui avait gardé des
vagues city abandonné craon enfin voilà
à branler du coup tous ses pains tout ça
ça s'est mis à pousser dans toutes les
directions
la nature se remplit très vite tout seul
et s'était complètement pas pénétrable
est vraiment impénétrable et on a acheté
ce bois bernard a découvert sa passion
du paysage en angleterre pays des
jardins où il a vécu plusieurs années
depuis ils s'insultent yves entretien au
total 6500 arbres et arbustes plusieurs
milliers d'espèces de plantes qui font
de l'arboretum des grandes bruyères un
conservatoire botanique d'espèces rares
les très grandes sélections ici chez les
magnolias
l'autre grande collection chez les
cornouillers vous êtes tous ces petits
arbustes qui sont fleurs en fleurs
autour de vous c'est les cornouillers de
chine
et puis on fleurit ya un mois un mois
plus tôt l'économie américain que les
américains appellent d'hormones et nous
on traduit boîte chez lg mccullough
l'écrire ça devait auger alors que cela
a causé pop dagwoods parce que le bois
de cornouaille est très dure et ça
servait de fourreaux dingue raccourci
dogues louvain naturellement des boîtes
cafards et les rats
et ça
bernard nonagénaire très en forme
continue à travailler inlassablement à
sa création
mais comme toute histoire d'amour il
faut être deux mais la deuxième c'est
brigitte sa femme
c'est vrai que ma femme on était deux
étaient deux comme elle est peintre elle
faisait ses portraits son travail de
peintre
jusqu'au jour où tout d'un coup à force
de me voir béchu est gratuite sera tracé
faire venir dès qu'on fait les blancs ça
l'a séduit intel de vxl la patronne
maintenant et qu'elle ne peut presque
plus jamais si on les veut beau il nous
faut chaque année quand elles ont fait
fleurir le défaire il va c'est pas
facile de passer de la peinture avec la
nature la nature fait ce qu'elle veut et
nous on cherche à adapter ce qu'on peut
car en somme tout ce qui est important
dans un jardin que ça soit une terrasse
que ça soit un tout petit jardin ça swan
immense arbre et à l'harmonie harmonie
partout de l'harmonie ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire la paix le paysage des
couleurs différentes et les couleurs qui
s'harmonisent et tout de suite on se
sent bien c'est ça qui est important
brigitte aidé d'une petite équipe de
salariés et bénévoles continuent à
développer l'arboretum
elle nous emmène dans la collection
d'amérique du nord coup pouce érable
liquidambar eychenne en amérique 200
espèces de chênes existe en europe seuls
une vingtaine subsiste une démission de
l'arboretum et la réimplantation
d'espèces disparues
à l'automne c'est l'amérique est
beaucoup plus intéressante que la chine
au point de vue coloris parce que c'est
sans fin vous avez le nid ça je vais
vous montrer le nice à sylvatica qu'il
vient absolument rouge cerise vous avez
chacun de ces chaînes qui ont les
coloris différents vous avez le
liquidambar y en a un qui devient roi
orange au qui vient rouge c'est vraiment
très bon nous avons la chance ici
d'avoir la récompense de 40 ans sans
avoir traité nîmes et des produits
chimiques
on a beaucoup peiné à ce qu'au départ
c'était tellement dur pas tout le monde
avait des roses comme ça avait des
fleurs comme ça et cetera parce qu'ils
mettaient les engrais dont nous on en
mettait pas alors c'était beau mais
malade et donc quarante ans après à
force cela prendre le savoir les soigner
et ben voilà
je
le travail de brigitte et bernard permet
aujourd'hui la conservation d'un
patrimoine botanique rares et sans doute
ressources potentielles notamment en
pharmacopée l'arboretum est aussi un
lieu pédagogique où chaque année 5000
personnes professionnels et grand public
viennent s'initier comprendre ou tout
simplement contempler de magnifique
paysage arboré